[Music]
today we're doing something a little
different today we are paying not one
game but three games if that doesn't
prove that I'm a gamer I don't know what
does three games in VR baby let's
freaking go for the first game is a
sonic simulator okay what do I need to
do type your actual height okay so five
hundred three meters nine meters
okay I'm 1.8 I don't care what anyone
says
here we go
Oh oh my god I'm Sonic baby this is the
dream thanks for coming
hi sir okay we gotta jump in
jump gun okay I think it comes to a
moment you realize I'm gonna throw up if
I play anymore so let's play more
friends I'm not playing this no way no
way I am NOT playing this game this is a
barfing simulator oh my god I'm getting
old okay I play the same before but I
really really really really want to play
it again it's called drunken bar fight
simulator and I'm ready to make action
with the people okay
please step up straight and pull trigger
oh you're gonna get the taste of the
Swedish meatballs Oh a game where you
stand it that my wife complains that she
always sees me as old oh yeah you gotta
pull yourself up Oh
my regretted never got a broke just here
[Applause]
Oh what are you going huh where are you
going come back here come back here stop
right there criminal scum what happened
welcome to my bar it's the worst in the
city oh yeah get drunk in this game I'm
a motivational speaker against alcohol
is a smell that I teach by example to
get the point across
smell this like decoration because I'm
just like them got a stay woke ass you
like this I told my wife look if you're
going to go out dressed like oh yeah
yeah yeah you like that don't get all
this bitching oh oh oh let's see
can just tell me if I should stop live
life like Marky Mark I always say oh
limbo limbo
you wanna limbo put it face you can't
judge me for being a job when it's part
of my job
how's your hairline going there buddy
[Music]
okay I thought you're gonna handle seven
sorry like me undefeatable yeah get up
get up goddamnit not like this not like
this I'm back I'm back god damn it he
got me from behind get up get up get
dammit get up I'm up I'm up I'm up
not there whoa the physics are so crazy
I hate my ex always telling me I drank
in park anybody you want to have you see
a lack of ambition but we see like a
doesn't bother him at all there you go
now you have hair you're welcome is that
a freaking mace yesterday there's some
mace
that's amazing you want a tip oh you
regret making me very angry
damn it come back here I messed up come
back and maze please let's go I love you
okay let's be gentle
sorry
[Applause]
no one knew
damn it was so close whoa well I win I'm
really good I felt sick for hours
yesterday I don't know why I can play
sometimes I play like no problem and
then sometimes I play a little bit and I
just want to die
but hopefully that won't happen again
okay let's go up here yeah let's go to
the roof guys so I didn't know you can
do this I don't know if it's a new thing
but we have a whole new roost hello
bankrupted a fortune 500 company because
Mark Cuban said I didn't have the balls
to okay Felix just act cool and you'll
blend right hey I once cured the
shingles oh my god okay yeah we can
mine's gonna be ready dad maybe next
time you should think so yeah this is
I'm mafia wax a way
stay away
[Applause]
they are too manly why the firewood
stay away sir
hold on
now I believe I have a sorry
I love you I love you so much
come here give me a hug give me a hug
please hit me I love you I love you me I
love you man we're friends right I
passed for a reason there it is your ass
is mine boy you damn it if the
helicopter comes it's over I have a good
divorce lawyer lined up at all of this
yeah it sucks being lonely but tonight
hell yeah I love this song oh you can't
judge me for being a drunk
ah it's part of my job what are you
[Applause]
no no damn I feel sexy
yeah damn I feel good but I'm also
[Applause]
myself excuse me
stay there stay back
how could you all right I'll return next
time stronger than ever
smash LIKE subscribe and bye bye guys
what cheaper simulators becoming
relevant no no don't leave
no please sponsor Eagles please do
something yes this game is still
relevant
dear me
[Music]